all right one last point before we go
today and this relates to jay-z who in
october of 2017 or late september wore
colin kaepernick jersey for a musical
performance on saturday night live he
was a big supporter of colin kaepernick
then he partners with the league earlier
this year and he says this isn't about
colin kaepernick getting a job this is
about moving forward and helping
millions of people and he got criticized
for that
and
and now the kaepernick thing is back on
the front burner thanks to the nfl
taking the pot and pulling it forward
and turning the heat up and it's been
strange this week chris because there
have been reports that jay-z was part of
the motivation for doing it i've heard
that he wasn't well jay-z hasn't said
anything about it it's very easy to post
a tweet it's very easy to make it known
in your own voice in your own name what
role if any you had in this and it
became even crazier over the weekend
sports illustrated reported that jay-z
was disappointed that colin kaepernick
turned this opportunity into a publicity
stunt and then yesterday roc nation the
agency and music business that that
jay-z owns they posted a tweet saying
according to a source jay-z has spoken
to no sources
and it's just odd to me that he's so
conspicuously quiet yeah if you
everybody's got an opinion on this right
this is the latest red state blue state
type of an issue you either support
colin kaepernick and you blame the nfl
or you don't support colin kaepernick
and you blame him for what happened
although i still think that there's a
middle ground where you understand both
sides are to blame and i'm trying to
stay in that strip but whatever jay-z's
take on it is
why don't you share it why don't you say
what you believe on this surely you have
an opinion that's what's odd to me that
he said nothing about this at a time
when everyone clearly has a view on it
well he he got a lot of backlash for
you know the fact that he struck this
deal with roc nation in the nfl to begin
with where yeah eric reid and a number
of players didn't like it because they
thought they he was capitalizing
off of the colin kaepernick issue and
doing those things that way and i think
you know ultimately that probably made
him a little gun shy in this
conversation to put himself out there
once again i do believe that he's firmly
in the corner of a colin kaepernick i do
and i you know i think from the get-go
last week i said i would think that
colin kaepernick has had a conversation
with roger goodell or maybe some of the
owners to maybe encourage this i don't
think he was like at 3 45 park ave in
the meeting rooms you mean jay-z jay-z
right i do think that he's probably had
that conversation i don't think he was
probably in 345 park ave over the last
month like banging his like hand on the
table like we gotta have a workout
happen you need to make it happen no i
think he's probably let it be known and
that's it and i do think the nfl and
roger goodell i take him at his word
that where we saw that adam what was it
adam schefter reported that you know
goodell felt bad about the situation in
general you know he's a human being
roger wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute i don't any time
this stuff is lit
he can come out and say why he did it i
don't need schefter to tell me what
because i the whole thing stinks to me
from every perspective so i'm not ready
to accept anything that anyone says
other than what they say in their own
voice and the only person who has spoken
in the last week in his own voice about
any of this is kaepernick if roger
goodell's got something to say he can
say so now he was he was asked about it
by gary myers and we've had access to
the video and he explained that this is
something that that was sparked by jeff
nally the agent for colin kaepernick his
memo from a month or so ago pointing out
that colin still hasn't gotten an
opportunity so goodell has said a little
bit
um but but i mean just look if jay-z's
got something to say back to the
original point if he's got something to
say say it and how do you not have
something to say on this how do you not
have an opinion on this it's just odd to
me that a guy with the influence of
jay-z who's previously supported
kaepernick who's gotten himself in a
little hot water from a pr standpoint
with the nfl partnership how do you
number one not have an opinion and
number two
not share it well he's hot i'm not
saying he's right or wrong i'm saying
it's odd well maybe he's contractly
contractually obligated not to say
anything with this whole thing maybe
this is one of the things in the
language of their contract that he
couldn't be too vocal about this
publicly or something like that i don't
know and again i'm all for what colin
kaepernick's fighting for i really am
would i kneel for the anthem absolutely
not i would not i would certainly stand
up for the national anthem and do that
but i understand what he's fighting for
but also at the same time right now that
was an absolute disaster this past
weekend it was and i know the nfl is
partly to blame and it seems like it was
a little poor it was not a little it was
poorly orchestrated and everything that
way but i also think colin kaepernick
did a poor job too to promote himself
you know again you're trying to get
teams to sign you and you're gonna wear
you know
a t-shirt that's got a lot of motives on
it you're gonna do a press conference
with a guy behind you who's got a hoodie
on that's a strip club like those aren't
things owners and coaches are going to
look at and go yeah no players no
players go to strip clubs they go but
they don't wear them in a press
conference when they don't have a job
i'm just telling you those are things
i'm just telling you a coach and an
owner of a team is going to look at and
go oh yup that's who i want on my team
you know every he won't ruffle any
feathers so that's the issue too i'm
just saying that's
i mean that's yeah i mean look there's a
lot of issues involved
and the bottom line is the guy the guy
isn't unemployed because of his football
abilities there are other issues that
have been totally played
for 32 months
and i don't think they want him back and
i don't think he wants to come back i
think i think both sides have used the
last week as a way to advance their own
pr and or legal agendas and as as we
explained during the show and one of the
reasons why they got spot number three
for me in the goats in a bad way draft
i'm upset that we've had to deal with
this we shouldn't have to you know the
nfl counts on us as the media to promote
their their sport they got they got a
great thing going think about it
they get paid billions for what amounts
to a three hour at a time infomercial
for their product so people will follow
and pay attention and pay money and buy
stuff and go to games
they get paid billions for that
infomercial and
there's a media out there
that covers it that fuels the machine
that writes about it and talks about it
and promotes the sport so while we're in
the process of promoting
organically and naturally the 2019
season the nfl's 100th season if you
haven't heard have you heard it's a
100th season
they they do this it's just it's
astounding to me and kaepernick made it
worse and they made it worse and it
ended up being a sideshow and a
distraction that no one wanted i didn't
want it you didn't want it nobody wanted
it nope and now now i want to go take a
nap yup i'm done it's exhausting
conversation because it is an emotional
one
oh and the other thing too is we got to
be careful about everything we say
because you never know we're going to
make this person mad or that person mad
somebody's getting upset look we didn't
want this folks they dropped this crap
onto us and we've had to deal with it
for the last week so shame on the nfl
and shame on colin kaepernick for
creating a distraction to what otherwise
is and was a very compelling football
season and we hope to get back to that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports